[Music]
a lot of financial advice out there
especially when it comes to crypto a lot
of fomo a lot of people trying to get in
on the next big coin and so i thought we
would watch a video together and just
see how you react to it john you ready
for this i am
people getting nutritional advice
and mental health advice
and now money advice from teenagers on
the tick tocks
that's congratulations america we've
done it roll the clip everyone gets a
platform okay everybody gets that's
right let's see what we got here
remember john your mic is hot so choose
your words
here's what would have happened had you
invested your 1200 stimulus check that
was first issued on april 12 2020 into
these top 10 most popular
cryptocurrencies twelve hundred dollar
investment into bitcoin today would now
be worth seven thousand five hundred and
thirty eight dollars twelve hundred
dollar investment into ethereum would be
worth twenty two thousand nine hundred
and twenty nine dollars into eta would
now be worth seventy six thousand three
hundred and sixty three dollars into bnb
would now be worth twenty eight thousand
seven hundred and twenty dollars twelve
hundred dollar investment into xrp would
now be worth five thousand eight hundred
and seventy three dollars into solana
would be worth a whopping two hundred
and ten thousand three hundred and
eighty nine dollars into chain link
would be worth eight thousand five
hundred and forty four dollars i think
he's doing that would be worth 126
thousand dollars into litecoin would be
four thousand five hundred and ninety
five dollars and a twelve hundred dollar
investment into tara luna would now be
worth one hundred and eighty thousand
dollars well george might have already
come back
they're back john wow you know what else
is cool if i had not gone to taco bell
yesterday i wouldn't have indigestion is
that how that works
you know what he didn't play he didn't
play the other 10th
gosh dude
so let's just recap what just happened
john first of all i think he made up
about 17 words in there how do people
just keep up man
uh and here's the other thing
hindsight is 20 20.
john you're an idiot if you invested in
apple in 1984 just a hundred dollars
you'd be a millionaire but you know if
you'd gotten off your horse in 1806 and
and and put some money in ford shares
you'd be a gajillionaire so john i was
just in vegas and i i put 16 black and i
went all in on it i won big you should
also put 16 on black next time you go
yeah because that's the winning number
this is such a terrible use of
statistics everybody
jeez i don't know if we can call it
statistics i think professors all over
are angry right well it's just this it's
this
oh man you got john all breathy america
look what you did because i hate the
manipulation of data to a make people
feel
dumb for choices they
could have made and i'm gonna go with
should've because we actually have real
doubt of what these things are worth
today oh yeah producer james pulled that
i can't stand it when people say
well if you had of so you should
because there is zero none zilch
correlation
right and it left out
10 000 other
crypto like like whatever cartoons drawn
with some kid's laptop it left all that
out who people lost their their minds
right so you take a narrow snapshot of
those things and it makes you feel
stupid and left out and then that's
going to encourage people to go make
some reckless choices with their money
and it's that kind of nonsense hurts
people it's not helpful no it's not
helpful not at all it just gets you it
makes you feel more homeless so you go i
missed out i missed out again on the
next big thing
and as we know timing the market is the
most dangerous thing you can do and we
say it's not about time in the market
it's not about timing the market it's
about time in the market it's about
consistency over time when it's up when
it's down you're consistent you're
investing in things that have a stable
long proven track record that's why we
recommend mutual funds over the next
meme coin that just came out so producer
james pulled up some using the same
logic pulled up some interesting stats
here if you had invested 1200 into
ethereum in november 2021 as of january
you would have 840.
there goes 400 bucks right there
if you invested 1200 into bitcoin in
early november 2021 as of mid-january
you would have 660 dollars
congratulations just lost half your
money
if you invested 1200 into dogecoin in
may of 2021 as of january you would have
360
instead of 1200. and i know this for a
fact john here's why
when we were doing the episode on
cryptocurrency on the fine print podcast
which you can go listen to wherever you
little school boys everywhere were angry
with you they yeah they're very upset
with me here's what i did i i had to
know the experience
of what it's like to actually invest in
something so i didn't spend more than i
was willing to lose
i put forty dollars into dogecoin it was
forty cents at the time so i got a
hundred dollar dogecoin and i went all
right let me just see the experience
number one it's traded 24 7. so i can be
up at 3 a.m watching it zing up and down
like a roller coaster going oh there
goes my money oop i made a dollar oh i
lost five dollars this is very stressful
so then we wonder why there's rampant
anxiety and stuff like following your
wife around be like you like me do you
like me now do you like me now how about
now so that was one piece of it but that
forty dollars can i tell you what it is
today john
according to that dude on the tick tocks
it's worth a hundred and eleven million
dollars it's worth fourteen dollars
that forty dollars turned into fourteen
just ride the wave and this was before
elon musk was saying hey doge to the
moon and he went on snl and everyone
thought this is our chance to get rich
quick and doge crashed after he went on
snl and mentioned
dogecoin so
don't let billionaires dictate how your
investments do hold on with one thing
they said on snl i'll i'll even give
billionaires like i think that's a good
like how'd you how did you if i see
somebody who's in great shape i might
ask them hey what are some things you do
in your life that puts you in a great
shape
and i got to filter that through my life
and my body and my blood types and my
experience and blah blah
who i'm not going to ask is some
nameless hand on the tick tocks
i don't know who that is
i don't know you know what i mean yeah i
don't know who that guy is i'm not gonna
say you're right i screwed up because i
don't even know if that is true i don't
know if that's accurate it's just
certainly not accurate right now you
know what i mean yeah gosh that's the
experience and generally if you're
telling someone to invest in a certain
coin it's because you invested in that
coin and if they invest then you make
more money it's like a multi-level
marketing scheme especially i think i'm
glad you brought that up and this is me
being totally serious
if somebody who's a billionaire comes
out on a platform and i'm not saying
they're evil guys but
they come out and say
here's where i'm putting my money
they know
that a bunch of people will rush out and
put their money there which props up the
price
and they can get out
and they've got a million followers or
10 million followers or 100 million
followers and so if you are trying to
it's like this how often have we
not you i'll say me thank you john how
often have i watched a pro athlete
documentary and i look at their workouts
and i'm like that's what i'm doing
tomorrow and i'll look start watching
their like the weights they're lifting
and squatting and i'll think all right i
need to up my game no
they play for a professional team this
is their job mine is to run my mouth on
the radio right i shouldn't be lifting
like a pro athlete yeah following the
dollar amounts and the scale that some
of these folks are investing in if that
thing goes down you know what they still
have a billion dollars you know you have
14. that was your whole life savings
while you're strapped with payments so
they can drag you into this thing prop
their thing up and get out and they've
got a their it's a much different game
they're playing even though the
the the the process looks the same yeah
so man don't make choices with your life
and don't invest in things that you
don't understand and i'll tell you john
i've done a lot of research on crypto
and nfts and the more i research it the
dumber i think i'm getting the i'm like
maybe i'm just not a smart person
because this is so complicated which
makes me think maybe it's not designed
to actually make me rich
it's designed to help other people get
rich and then get out
so there's your uh your little pro tip
for the day on cryptocurrency if you
want to learn more about this stuff we
did a whole episode on the fine print
all about the hidden truths that are
keeping people broke it's called could
bitcoin be your ticket to wealth and if
you want to join us we are going to be
going to orlando with a building wealth
event where we show you the right way to
build wealth so you can check all that
out at ramseysolutions.com thank you for
making me dumber today george you're
welcome it wasn't hard
i don't know what that says about it
it's a low bar